pandora paper's biggest ever leak of
offshore data exposes financial secrets
of rich and powerful this is a guardian
story kai if you can pull it up as well
millions of documents reveal offshore
deals assets of more than 100
billionaires 30 world leaders 300 public
officials branded the pandora papers the
cache included 11.9 million files from
companies hired by wealthy clients to
create offshore structure and trust in
tax havens such as panama dubai monaco
switzerland cayman islands the pandora
papers represent the latest and the
largest in terms of data volume in the
series of major leaks of financial data
that have con convulsed the offshore
world since 2013. the famous ones on the
uh that appear in pandora's papers
shakira ringo starr tony blair king
abdullah ii of jordan guillermo lasso
president of ecuador elton john claudia
scheifer and uh schiffer and amongst
many other names who else do you have
here tony blair yeah we've talked about
those guys
vladimir putin's also on there the
papers revealed the extraordinary hidden
wealth of russian president vladimir
putin's inner circle his childhood
friend and an alleged former lover are
amongst those revealed to have amassed
extraordinary wealth hidden through
offshore companies okay uh what do you
think about this gerard
this uh
this just goes to show guys that there
is a completely different world out
there when we talk about the global
elites and people are like oh it's a
conspiracy you're going crazy again how
many more times do you need to see it
how many times do you need to see the
the the uh panama papers how many times
you need to see the pandora papers how
many times do you need to have who
how many more jeffrey epstein's do you
need to have be paraded in front of you
you know how many more times do you have
to read about the pan the uh the
pentagon papers guys
there is a completely different world
out there for the global elites that we
know nothing about that while they're
taxing you and taking all of your stuff
all right and taking your future and
right now they're going to raise the
debt limit where okay what what where
does that money go that money goes how
does trump pull us out of the paris
accords how does he pull us out of the
who okay so our money goes to nato
american tax dollars goes to nato goes
to the paris accords the
the climate change this climate change
climate change this and that
and then it all ends up
where
in these offshore accounts with these
globalist oligarchs it's a big club as
the late great george carlin would say
and you
ain't in it and the person here that i
feel most disgusted about is julian
assange julian assange is gonna die in a
prison
he's going to die in a prison for
exposing the truth julian assange the
founder of wikileaks is going to die and
they're probably the elites will
probably have his name stricken from the
records and there'll be a few crazy q
anon conspiracy theorists on a
blockchain 100 years from now talking
about there was a guy named julian
assange who knew that all this stuff was
going on knew that there was sex
trafficking going on knew that there was
offshore accounts where people were
using diamonds to to you know sell
access and they were funneling billions
and billions and billions of
hard-working everyday people's money
into their own freaking pockets while
they're dividing us down
uh you know what i can go for another
hour and a half don't don't get me
started on this guys if
if you're not reading this if you're not
paying attention to this and if you
don't see what's actually going on i
will we can't help you anymore but why
is this any any of this new
like this has been going on for years we
all saw on the wolf of wall street swiss
bank accounts jordan belford strapping
money onto people you brought up the
panama papers
wealthy people shocker alert don't want
to give up all their loot to the
government it's not it is what it is
it's not the money right it the money
the money is is the hypocrisy where
they'll sit there and they'll tell you
that you're not paying your fair share
and i need to take another 25 of mr bet
david's wealth because i need blah blah
blah there's poor kids and you know
starving in sarasota and then the money
ends up where okay we we don't have a
revenue problem in this country and they
want to do a global tax now mind you
they're they're they're the global taxes
coming global business taxes coming
global income taxes coming it's all
coming right so we
whatever amount of revenue we generate
they don't pay their taxes it goes to
their offshore they don't play the the
rules that they make us play by they
don't play by those rules so the
hypocrisy pisses people off and i can
understand because the average person
that doesn't have 50 million dollars
more than that figure out half the
person doesn't have 50 000. you have to
understand the access that's being sold
this is this is an access game this is
okay tony blair tony blair the prime
minister of of uh
great britain our biggest ally in the
world the head of nato right the front
lines on on europe
now you make 250 000 pounds a year buddy
where did you get 100 million dollars
how
where'd you get that money bud
you you make 200 grand where'd you get
the money
you you got caught with 50 million where
where'd you get that money buddy
what deals are being made that we don't
know
what access is being sold that we don't
you understand what i'm saying they want
to go after they want to go after
trump's uh uh tax reports how man how
long do we hear about trump's tax
reports we need trump's tax returns we
need trump's tax returns he's lying
about his money he's actually a deca
millionaire he's not a billionaire and
then these guys have have the balls to
have 100 million dollars stored offshore
where'd they get the money dude
where how did they acquire this well
well you're oh i mean tony blair good
question but obviously everyone else on
this list elton john
uh
vladimir putin yeah exactly we know
where they got the frickin money i mean
they got the freak but something that
you're i don't know honestly discounting
there is an entire profession in this
country called estate planners trusts
and estates attorneys tax attorneys i go
to a conference called the heckerling
estate planning conference i'll be going
in january there's an entire
occupation
that the elite
mega billionaire multi-millionaires hire
these tax estate to avoid estate taxes
it's all legal
it's all legal where's the revenue
coming from what do you mean the revenue
see
i'm saying these people are saying these
people have these money and they're
they're legally avoiding estate taxes
yeah but he's saying he's like where's
250 thousand dollars he uh generated how
many millions of money but i can assure
that we know where elton john got his
money and tony okay king abdullah got
his money right of cyprus ringo starr
got his money some of these people
actually made this money they just want
to avoid taxes which i'm okay with
taxation's theft baby i really don't
care so
which one is it you like save that much
and yeah i say keep that money so which
one is more concerned with where they
got the money i'm more concerned with
the head of the state is where they got
the money sure
does this hurt them
these guys right now who are on that
list sitting there pissed off that these
things are public do you think they're
frustrated about it
look yeah okay what's a bad look on it
what's the bad look the fact that they
have offshore money money offshore no
good stuff this changes anything yeah we
know that rich people do stuff to avoid
taxes okay
you know how they got the money good
question but that's something pelosi we
saw what happened with pelosi that
there's two business models one go make
it yourself two go create the laws to
benefit you i mean that's the politician
yeah i mean it's it's not anything new
that's going on i just wondered this
this i mean this keeps happening over
and over and over again people are
fascinated with knowing how much money
people have you know oh my god let me
see how much money this guy is let me
see where he has his money at but do you
think these guys were getting these
papers hoping other people's names were
on there and they were disappointed is
it kind of like i was hoping we should
have trump or we were opening someone oh
okay let's just put it out there and it
wasn't write it up are you saying the
guardian or whoever whoever got this
were they were some of these guys so
excited to have other names on their
shakira okay good for shakira you know
what this tells me with shakira whoever
accountant is and whoever cpas she's
probably got better ones than j.lo does
so you know who's who's shakira's people
working for her that's advising on
things like this but no i i i think
maybe they were looking for other names
too that was going to be a little bit
bigger and it didn't hit and quite
frankly those people are disappointed
all the other guys every
few years you're going to find out where
the wealth especially nowadays people
getting better at getting this kind of
information so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]